Welcome and join us on this deep dive into Reza Shakazemi's spiritual ethos, exploring its subject, the closing portrait of the Imam, peace be upon him, and his spiritual ethos, tracing joy, beauty, detachment, and the hereafter in one seamless arc.
Glad to be here for this one.
The fruit of good action is like its root goodness already tastes the hereafter, here and now.
That is
Such a dense starting point.
I mean, think about the smartest person Just picture the most brilliant, highly educated expert you can think of in your life.
Okay, I have a few people in mind.
Are they also the happiest person you know?
Oh, definitely not.
Usually they're the most stressed.
We have been conditioned, practically from birth, to believe that acquiring knowledge is like gathering bricks.
It's this heavy, cold, exhausting process.
But today, we are looking at a total inversion of that assumption.
We're exploring why knowledge is actually the most joyful act a human being can undertake.
We must begin by looking at the specific crisis of our current age.
You know, how we actually view knowledge today.
Because our civilization has basically trained you to picture knowledge as something fundamentally dry.
It's abstract.
It's completely separated from your inner life.
It's just data.
It is.
It's treated as a bloodless accumulation of facts or just the mechanical running of procedures.
In this modern framing, you can acquire vast amounts of information.
You can become an undisputed master in your field, and yet your heart remains completely unchanged.
Unmoved by any of it.
Because knowledge is seen merely as a utilitarian instrument.
It's a tool we use to manipulate the physical world.
to build bridges or cure diseases or win arguments online, but it is entirely divorced from the condition of the soul.
That divorce leaves the soul so impoverished.
And you can see it in how exhausted modern people feel, even when they're surrounded by limitless information.
We have all the facts in the world, but very little gladness.
And this is where we encounter the imam's radical claim, which turns our modern assumption completely upside down.
In the collected sermons, he states that the most joyous of mankind is the intellectual.
Just sit with the weight of that inversion for a moment.
He does not say the wisest person is simply most correct or the most accurate or the most well-read.
He says the wisest is the happiest.
That feels so counterintuitive to how we live.
It does.
The brutal, agonizing struggle against the ego, the campaign against the caprice of one's own soul and that heavy pull of appetite,
This is not waged merely to avoid defeat.
It is waged for joy.
The discipline of the mind and the purification of the heart are directed toward a profound, lasting delight.
We can frame this pursuit of knowledge as a homecoming from the exile of ignorance.
I mean, think about what it actually means to be in exile.
It's a painful state.
It is.
To be ignorant is not simply to have an empty folder on a computer hard drive just, you know, waiting for data.
To be ignorant is to be lost in a hostile wilderness.
That's a powerful way to put it.
Is to be
from your own true nature and from reality itself.
It's a state of cold, disoriented wandering.
When you do not know who you are or what the world is, you suffer.
You're just stumbling in the dark.
Therefore, to know in this deep spiritual sense is to find the way back.
It's the joy of arriving at the hearth after a long, freezing banishment.
The warmth of the fire is the truth you finally comprehend.
Finding the way back requires a map, though.
And for the Imam, that map begins with the priority of worship.
It's
It's crucial to examine where worship sits in his order of things because, well, it is not where modern people usually put it.
Where do we usually put it?
At the end of the day, if there's time left over.
If we put it anywhere at all, yes.
But we find a profound doorway in the Quranic verse, chapter 6, verse 162, which provides the foundational sequence.
It says, say, truly my worship and my sacrifice and my living and my dying are for God, Lord of the universes.
Notice the specific order of the words there.
Worship is placed before living, before dying, and before death.
or sacrifice.
Worship comes first.
It is not an afterthought and it is not merely a formal obligation.
You just add on to an already busy schedule.
Worship is the central pillar because it sustains a dimension of the soul that simply withers without it.
Starves.
There is a part of the human being that yearns to turn toward its creator.
If you deny that turning, if you pretend that dimension does not exist, that part of you just.
The deepest reason to give this spiritual dimension its due is not out of a begrudging sense of bureaucratic duty.
You do not worship simply because you are told to.
You worship because of the immense reward that lies on the far side of it.
And what is that reward?
It is what the Imam describes in his counsel to the disciple he counsels as intimacy with the spirit of certainty.
Those who have received the life of the spirit rejoice in this intimacy.
I don't buy that yet.
How can knowledge be joy when it feels so dry and cold?
Intellectual work doesn't feel like a physical embrace.
That's a fair challenge.
When you are sifting through difficult philosophical concepts or trying to discipline your mind, it often feels alienating.
and exhausting.
It feels like strenuous effort, not an intimate reunion.
So how do we bridge the gap?
How do we bridge the gap between the grueling work of the intellect and this overwhelming intimate joy you are describing?
I hear that pushback, and it is crucial to address it by unpacking the paradox of what fundamental truths actually are.
We have to break down the language here for a second.
Okay, let's break it down.
The concept of intimacy we are discussing is rooted in a specific Arabic term, pashara,
which translates to a state of direct physical contact.
Like actually touching something.
It does not mean arriving at a cold logical conclusion.
It doesn't mean looking at a mathematical proof, verifying the equations and just nodding your head.
It means to touch and to be touched by the real.
That's a very different experience of knowing.
Engaging with fundamental truths is not about memorizing data.
It is a return to being itself.
Reality, the sheer fact of existence, cannot be divided.
There is no second reality alongside the absolute.
Because the absolute is all there is.
Therefore, the being of a single human person cannot, at its deepest foundation, be something other than being itself.
Because reality is undivided, knowing reality is the ultimate form of self-discovery.
And coming to know what truly is, you are coming home to what you most deeply are, the grueling effort you mentioned earlier.
That is simply the friction of the ego.
resisting this reality.
That homecoming requires a toll then.
A heavy toll.
It demands the deepest possible effacement of the small I.
The ego.
The fragile, separate ego that constantly seeks its own validation, that feels exhausted by study, that feels threatened by what it does not know, that ego must be let go.
The joy we are speaking of belongs to the core of existence, not to the ego.
Think about how unstable ego-driven pleasure actually is.
It's incredibly fragile.
A pleasure that belongs to the ego rises and falls with the ego's fortunes.
If you receive praise, you are happy.
If someone criticizes you an hour later, you are completely devastated.
But the joy of certainty is unshakable because it is the gladness of being itself, tasted most fully in the very act of the ego's surrender.
The divine beatitude, the sheer contentment of the soul, is described as greater than the garden of paradise.
Wait, greater than paradise itself?
The joy of this touch is greater than the ultimate destination of heaven itself.
It depends entirely on your soul being true to the spirit within it.
This brings us to a specific type of person, the one who embodies the certainty.
The texts redefine a common term, which we can translate conceptually as
The one who truly understands.
Let's unpack that because it's so easily misunderstood.
In a conventional sense, people often assume that the one who truly understands religion or philosophy is, well, the most severe person in the room.
The strictest one.
We picture the strictest judge, the one who is quickest to point out flaws, the one who delivers the harshest rulings and sets the most rigid boundaries.
That's usually imamate we have of a religious scholar.
But the imam completely overturns this assumption.
He says the one who truly understands is recognized
their merciful bearing.
They never make a soul despair of God's mercy.
And we need to pause here, because despair is not just a sad feeling.
In this framework, despair is an error in knowledge.
An epistemic error.
To give up on mercy is a failure to know the divine as it has revealed itself.
The divine has prescribed mercy for himself.
Consider the gravity of that statement.
The all-powerful has bound himself to compassion.
So if you despair, you are fundamentally misunderstanding the nature of reality.
For a person to truly understand this, they must be so immersed in the joyous certainty of that mercy that despair simply cannot take root in them.
Their certainty in this boundless mercy brings an unshakable joy.
And that joy radiates outward.
It radiates outward as a merciful bearing toward everyone they encounter.
They do not act as gatekeepers to a closed fortress.
They act as guides to an open sanctuary.
If you have this joyous certainty, this merciful bearing, it changes how you interact with the physical world around you too.
It changes everything.
We encounter another unexpected element in this spiritual landscape.
This opening onto joy through intimate knowledge turns out to be inseparable from something our modern age rarely associates with rigorous intellect.
Beauty.
We have been conditioned to think of beauty as something purely decorative.
We treat it as a subjective flourish, you know, a matter of personal taste that you just add on after the real work of thinking is done.
Like putting a nice coat of paint on a house after it's built.
But in this ethos, beauty is not a decoration.
Appreciating the beautiful is what a rightly working intelligence is actually for.
It is an
intrinsic function of the intellect.
The connection here leads us straight to the heart of virtue.
The literal meaning of virtue in this context is making beautiful.
Making beautiful, let that sink in.
The excellence of the intellect is found in the beauty of things outward, but it is completed and anchored by a beauty of soul within.
Virtue is the active, deliberate process of making the soul beautiful.
It is not just about avoiding bad deeds.
It is an aesthetic triumph of the inner life.
Let us examine our second governing image.
The soul made beautiful, drawing down the love of the beautiful.
This image rests on 2 essential sayings from the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
What are those sayings?
The first is that God is beautiful and loves beauty.
The second is the command to assume the character traits of God.
When you lay these two together, a complete, seamless spiritual program emerges.
If the divine is beautiful and loves beauty, and if your calling as a human being is to assume those divine character traits, then virtue is far more profound than following a set of external rules.
It's not just a checklist of do's and don'ts.
Virtue is the active work of making yourself lovable to the divine.
It is the cultivation of inner beauty so that you might draw down the love of the one who loves the beautiful.
It is an upward reach of human love met by a downward reach of divine love, and the meeting place is the beautiful soul.
The virtues required for this, kindness, contentment, courtesy, generosity and modesty, and a wise, unhurried forbearance are what give the intellect depth.
Forbearance is such a key word there.
It's the strength to hold your temper and absorb a wrong without being diminished by it.
Without these traits, the mind remains trapped on a flat, horizontal plane of mere rationality.
Virtue aerates the intelligence.
The Aga Khan has expanded beautifully on this principle.
He has argued that beauty in the made world, whether it is the perfect tadence of a line of verse, the harmonious proportions of a building, or the meticulous care put into a garden, is not a luxury.
It's not just extra fluff.
This crafted beauty ennobles life.
It serves as a physical reminder that turns the soul back toward its source.
Laboring for the beautiful in the physical world is a mode of searching for the divine.
The work of making beautiful runs continuously from the inner state of a single individual's heart to the outward architecture of a whole community.
But we must look at what happens when this process is corrupted, because a portrait of virtue inevitably casts a shadow.
Vices are not just moral failings.
They are blind spots.
They are diseases of the heart that destroy the intellect's power to see.
And the subtlest, most insidious darkening of the heart is pretension.
Pretension
Performing for the crowd.
Pretension is the performance of piety for the watching crowd.
It is doing something outwardly good, but doing it entirely to be seen by others.
Pretension is devastating because it wears the exact mask of devotion.
It looked like virtue from the outside.
You can't tell the difference just by looking.
You might see someone giving generously in the public square or leading the community in long prayers, but the diagnosis here is unsparing.
Pretension is the subtlest idol.
The subtlest idol.
That is a terrifying phrase.
It is the setting up of partners beside the divine.
When you perform a good deed, not out of a pure inner alignment, but simply to be praised by the people around you, have made an idol of your audience.
You have placed their gaze above the gaze of the real.
You are worshipping their approval.
This leads to a severe yet ultimately freeing rule regarding human action.
Action is dust, except what is purified within it.
You can perform 1000 outwardly impressive deeds.
You can build monuments of charity.
You can exhaust yourself in public service.
You can be celebrated by your entire community as a pillar of righteousness.
But if the intention within those actions is corrupted by the desire for public acclaim, the actions themselves are merely dust blowing in the wind.
Only the sincerity inside the deed survives the sifting.
Only the pure, beautiful intention has weight in the scales of eternity.
The fruit of good action is like its root goodness already tastes the hereafter here and now.
This brings us to a crucial pivot in our examination.
We must consider the demanding counsel provided regarding how the wise interact with the difficulties of the world.
Because it's not all just joy and beauty in a vacuum.
There's hardship.
The texts state that the wise make easy what the extravagant find harsh.
They befriend what estranges the ignorant.
They do not merely endure hardship with gritted teeth.
They actively befriend it.
I have to stop you there.
Isn't this just a sour hatred of the physical world?
The imam calls the world a chewed up bone.
How does that reconcile with loving its beauty?
It does sound contradictory at first glance.
It sounds like a grim, ascetic rejection of everything physical.
If we are supposed to appreciate the beauty of the made world, as we just discussed, and see how it turns the soul back to its source, how can we simultaneously view the world as contemptible?
How is this not just an ascetic, miserable hatred of physical life?
This tension is vital to navigate and requires careful distinction.
Detachment does not mean a sour war against the body or a hatred of the physical realm.
Detachment overcomes worldliness, not the world itself.
Okay, unpack the difference between the world and worldliness.
Worldliness is the egoistic clinging to passing things.
It is treating temporary conditions, wealth, status, physical comfort as if they were ultimate realities.
The world is only small when it's compared directly to the absolute.
The imam who calls the world a chewed up bone is the very same imam who speaks with unmistakable wonder about the beauty of the peacock and the marvels of virgin nature.
So it's about proportion.
The world is contemptible only when it is loved for itself, as an idol, as a final destination.
But it is glorious when it is seen as a hymn.
The world still hymns God's praise.
Every created thing points beyond itself to the Creator.
We can understand this through the story of Joseph.
In the scriptures, Joseph's brothers deemed him of little value and sold him for a paltry price.
The word used to describe their valuation of him is the root of the word for detachment.
Detachment is placing little value on the world when it is weighed against eternity.
It is not that the world has zero value, but its value is instrumental, not ultimate.
When you detach from the frantic pursuit of worldly accumulation, you experience a strange enlargement of the soul.
Think about how much energy is consumed by anxiety over worldly status, just constantly worrying about how you are perceived.
The less your soul is crowded by that anxiety, the more room it has for the real.
Detachment does not subtract from your life.
It expands your capacity to experience true existence.
This expansion leads us to the ultimate detachment, which is the contemplation of death.
We introduce our third governing image here, death as something deeply familiar and nurturing.
The imam says death is more intimate than the mother's breast is to the suckling babe.
He is speaking of death not as something to be braved or stoically endured, but as the nearest and most nourishing of intimacies.
Consider the state of the suckling babe.
It is fragile, entirely dependent, seeking warmth and sustenance.
The mother's breast represents total integration, safety, and the quenching of a fundamental thirst.
That sounds like wordplay.
Isn't loving death just dressing up a fear of it?
It can sound like that, sure.
It feels like a psychological defense mechanism.
To call death a mother's breast sounds like a poetic way to avoid confronting the terrifying reality of non-existence and the violent severance from everything we know and love in this life.
How can the end of life be framed as a nurturing intimacy?
Let us look closer at the mechanism of dying to self while still alive.
The texts are pointing toward an extinction of the ego before the absolute.
Meaning you don't wait for physical death.
Life, when lived purely within the confines of the ego, is actually a walled-in privation.
You are trapped in a tiny fortress of your own anxieties, your desires, your need to defend your identity.
It's exhausting just holding up those walls.
To extinguish that ego is not to cease existing.
It is to plunge into the infinite plenitude of the divine realms.
Death for the wise is a release.
It is an integration.
It is a profound mode of tawhid, of ultimate unification with the one.
Oh, I see.
The ignorant recoil from death because they think their small walled in ego is their true and only life.
They confuse the prison for the self.
But the surrender of that small self is the only ground upon which infinite life can be experienced.
Okay, I see it now.
When you frame it as dying to the small self, the resistance begins to dissolve.
If the ego is a clenched fist, opening the hand feels like death to the fist, but it is the only way to hold anything else.
That's a beautiful way to see it.
I can see how this perspective was embraced by those who walked this path deeply.
The early Sufi master understood that to die to the small self is not to be extinguished, but to be raised into a higher unobstructed life.
And the Persian poet articulated this beautifully when he asked his companions not to weep at his funeral, because for him, death was not an ending, but a wedding.
A wedding, the ultimate union.
It is the consummation toward which the entire life of the spirit has been quietly moving.
The intimacy of the mother's breast makes perfect sense if the soul has already practiced surrendering its boundaries through love and knowledge.
To ground these incredibly high concepts, we must look at a historical example of what happens when the outward form of devotion is completely severed from this inner dying to self.
Let us examine the historical pious rebels.
We need to steel man their devotion to understand the contrast clearly.
Let's give them their due.
Picture them at their absolute strongest, their most about.
These
individuals celebrated throughout their communities for their scriptural reading.
They performed punishing night-long vigils of worship.
They fasted relentlessly.
Their outward zeal was unmatched, and they were admired by many for the sheer physical stamina of their piety.
They possessed A discipline that most people could not even begin to emulate.
And yet they lacked the fundamental core of what the Imam teaches.
They lacked the inner beauty, the merciful bearing, the true understanding that prevents despair.
Their zeal had turned bitter.
It was a caricature of true devotion.
They were severe, harsh, and quick to judge.
And so the imam delivered a startling rebuke to his own supporters, who were expressing admiration for these rebels.
He told them, sleeping with certainty is better than praying with doubt.
Think about the magnitude of that statement.
Picture the rebel who hasn't slept in three days, who is physically exhausted from continuous prayer.
The imam basically looks at him and says, you would be better off taking a nap if you actually knew what you were doing.
The mechanism behind this rebuke is profound.
Worship without the seeing heart is nothing more than mechanical motion.
It's just gymnastics.
The bodily rest of a soul that is inwardly awake to higher realities, a soul resting in the joyous certainty of divine mercy, takes absolutely nothing away from its true wakefulness.
The pious rebels were physically awake all night, but spiritually they were completely blind.
True intellect is the seeing heart.
If you do not have that seeing heart, if you do not possess the inner virtue of making beautiful, then the most strenuous physical devotion is entirely disconnected from the divine.
It becomes an exercise in ego, a form of spiritual pride masquerading as submission.
The obedience to the command to pray is necessary, but it is not sufficient on its own.
There must be a profound consciousness of what you are doing and why.
This awareness joins seamlessly to inward beauty that actually draws down divine acceptance.
The hereafter is not a distant future payment that you were waiting for after a long, miserable life of deprivation.
The hereafter is already beneath our feet.
The imam counsels us to cast the eye of the heart toward the garden, to trees whose roots lie hidden in dunes of musk.
This is not a rhetorical flourish meant to bribe you into good behavior.
It's a description of a vision.
It is a foretaste.
that is actually available right now to the soul that has grown still uncertain.
It changes the entire landscape of how you live your life today.
The texts ask a penetrating question.
Is the reward of goodness ought but goodness?
Goodness and its reward are made of the exact same substance.
You do not endure the bitter medicine of goodness now to get a sweet candy of reward later.
The goodness itself contains the sweetness.
On the classical Ismaili reading, salvation is not merely a verdict delivered at the end of time by a distant judge.
Salvation is a deliverance that begins right now, today, grounded in unshakable certitude.
Heaven is being tasted in every act of pure intention, in every cultivation of inner beauty, and in every moment of true intellectual joy.
The fruit of good action is like its goodness only tastes the hereafter, here and now.
The spiritual ethos we have explored reveals a life where knowing, loving, and living are fused into a single act and that act is joy.
The wisest person is the happiest, not despite their rigorous discipline, but entirely because of it.
The most detached person is the most fully alive.
The one who is most intimately acquainted with the death of the ego is the one who has truly begun to live.
Which good do you already know you've refused to begin?